unsere welt ist anders als bisher
angenommen es geht lediglich um ein
kleines detail aber mit großen
auswirkungen messen haben nämlich
aktuell gezeigt dass der offizielle wert
des protonenradius wohl nicht korrekt
ist und das hat nicht nur für die physik
sondern auch für viele weitere bereiche
der wissenschaft auswirkungen wie genau
diese kleine revolution in der physik
aufgenommen wird und welche folgen sich
daraus ergeben jetzt bei klick zum
science fiction bei uns gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen also erstens der
offizielle standardwert für den radius
eines protons liegt bei 0 8768 femto
metern doch schon in den letzten jahren
gab es immer mal wieder zweifel an den
offiziellen werten des protons
angefangen hatte alles im jahr 2010
hatte ein deutsches forschungsteam einen
protonenradius ermittelt der rund vier
prozent unter dem standardwert lag
dieses ergebnis erhielten sie mit hilfe
der laserspektroskopie einer proton
million verbindung die studio sorgte für
hitzige diskussionen und erregte große
unruhe in der physik welt viele
fachleute gingen davon aus dass die
messungen fehlerhaft waren andere ließen
aber auch zum ersten mal den gedanken zu
dass der alte werth nicht korrekt sein
könnte
manche spekulierten sogar über eine bis
dahin unbekannte physikalische kraft
dazu einer der studienautoren randolf
pohl aus mainz nachdem 2010 unsere erste
studie heraus gekommen war fürchtete ich
dass sich ein altgedienter physiker
melden und uns auf einen groben
schnitzer hinweisen würde aber die jahre
sind vergangen und bis heute ist nichts
dergleichen passiert
im gegenteil 2016 legte das
forschungsteam nach und präsentierte
eine weitere studie die ebenfalls
kleinere werte für den protonenradius
nahelegte auch in diesem experiment
wurde die laserspektroskopie angewandt
diesmal allerdings zur messung des
dorian kerns einem wasserstoff isotope
also eine variante des wasserstoffs der
atomkern von deuterium besteht lediglich
aus einem neutron und einem proton und
auch hier ergab sich die rätselhafte
diskrepanz die darauf schließen lässt
dass eine fundamentale größe der physik
bisher falsch bestimmt worden war
der radius des protons
anfang des letzten jahres 2017 entdeckte
ein forschungsteam vom max planck
institut für kernphysik dann einen
weiteren hinweis denn die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ermittelten auch für die masse des
protons abweichungen vom standardwert
das proton zeigte sich signifikant
leichter als bislang gedacht konkret
zeigte sich der unterschied erst ab der
neunten nachkommastelle das ist zwar
wenig aber spielt trotzdem für die
physik eine riesenrolle denn nicht nur
der protonen radio sondern eben auch die
proton masse haben in der physik eine
fundamentale bedeutung denn die
neutronen bilden zusammen mit den
protonen den atomkern somit gelten sie
als fundamentale bausteine aller materie
die zahlreichen abweichenden messwerte
machen physiker teams weltweit nervös
denn auch naturkonstanten wie etwa die
so genannte rietberg konstante sind von
proton abhängig sie wird in der
quantenmechanik eingesetzt um die
wellenlängen der spektrallinien von
atomen zu bestimmen ein falscher
offizieller standardwert ist demnach
also fatal
somit war es höchste zeit die
vorliegenden ergebnisse der drei
messungen zu verifizieren
das hat das team vom max planck institut
für quantenoptik in garching vor einiger
zeit getan und zwar anhand des normalen
wasserstoffatoms hier konnte die messung
nicht durch den austausch des elektrons
durch das schwere million verfälscht
werden konkret analysierten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die spektrallinien des wasserstoffatoms
und zwar bei zwei verschiedenen energie
übergängen zum einen bei einem so
genannten 1 s 2 s übergang bei dem das
elektron nach anregungen in den
grundzustand zurückfällt und dabei eine
besonders dünne spektrallinien erzeugt
das zweite experiment untersuchte den
wechsel zwischen zwei angeregten
zuständen und zwar bei dem sogenannten 2
s 4 p übergang hier wurden die atome
durch einen laser zunächst angeregt und
fielen dann in einen niedrigeren zustand
zurück hierbei sendeten sie photonen aus
wodurch das forschungsteam rückschlüsse
auf die protonen größe ziehen konnte
das ergebnis der beiden experimente ist
mehr als eindeutig dass proton ist
demnach kleiner als bisher angenommen
demnach liegt der protonenradius bei 0,8
35 kilometern und nicht bei den bislang
offiziell 0,87 68 zentimetern es handelt
sich hierbei also um werte die um bis zu
fünf prozent unter den standardwert
liegen und bei diesem ergebnis kann man
sich eigentlich sehr sehr sicher sein
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
thomas denn unsere messung ist fast so
genau wie alle anderen bisherigen
experimente an regulärem wasserstoff
zusammengenommen
dazu kommt das team vom max planck
institut hat die ermittelten daten sehr
genau unter die lupe genommen
insgesamt drei jahre lang haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
diese geprüft um eventuelle messfehler
auszuschließen
dennoch betont das forschungsteam das
andere methoden und weitere messung
wichtig sein um wirklich auf nummer
sicher zu gehen doch schon jetzt ist das
offizielle gremium für solche
angelegenheiten ganz ohr und zwar ist
die rede vom sogenannten committee on
data for science and technology das
standardwerte für konstanten in der
physik festlegt dazu ein sprecher wir
werden dieses ergebnis sehr ernst nehmen
höchstwahrscheinlich wird der offizielle
wert für den radius der protonen und
somit auch die rietberg konstante schon
sehr bald geändert werden wenn ihr dazu
und zu allen anderen themen nichts
verpassen wollt dann endet meine
handynummer auf whatsapp das geht
einfach hier
dann schicke ich jedem von euch alle
nachrichten mit dem link zum aktuellen
video und zwar noch bevor sie abonnenten
hier auf youtube zu sehen bekommen und
ihr bekommt zur begrüßung ein kleines
geschenk also hier draufklicken abo da
lassen und auf jeden fall das video
dafür auch noch draufklicken sehen
geheimnisvolles teilchen entdeckt bis
dann bleibt dran